hello students all set to rock the
examination I'm pretty sure you are well
there's a very important question which
has been asked by students nowadays and
that is now what to do if I know all the
answers right even the questions which
are given in the choices I can answer
them so should I answer all the
questions because I'm writing also very
well right the simple answer to this is
please follow the instructions given on
your question paper why so because when
you write the answers for the question
which are in choices you are losing on
your precious time which you can use for
retaking your answers isn't it and not
only this on the other hand you're also
confusing The Examiner which has to be
considered for marking so instead of
doing this please answer only that
question for which you know how to
beautifully present your answer and
that's all hope this helps for your
examination all the best